ceremonia solemne muy intensa la del
funeral de Benedicto 16 miles de
personas asistieron a la misa en la
plaza de San Pedro en un ambiente de
profunda devoción un momento intenso
para muchas personas Vimos a algunos de
los fieles aquí presentes visiblemente
emocionados el féretro con los restos de
Benedicto 16 colocados simplemente en el
suelo con un evangelio todos los
cardenales y obispos presentes vestidos
de rojo claramente Esta es una escena
una imagen que marcará la historia de la
Iglesia Católica es la primera vez en
600 años que se asiste al funeral de un
papa emérito en su homilía el Papa
Francisco rindió homenaje a su
predecesor habló de su sabiduría de su
delicadeza expresó su agradecimiento
hacia Benedicto 16 elogió la dedicación
que ha mostrado a lo largo de los años
al final de la misa el féretro de
Benedicto 16 fue inmediatamente
trasladado a las grutas bajo la Basílica
de San Pedro para el entierro en la
antigua tumba que ocupaba el ataúd de
Juan Pablo II antes de ser canonizado
ser enterrado en esta tumba fue uno de
los últimos deseos de Benedicto 16